one of my favorite Latin words is um
Akron which means in order to pass
through Heaven you have to go through
hell and so it's like that's like in
order to get to the other side of fear
you have to pass right through it the
way I manage fear is like most people
think of it being kind of like a
disabling sort of emotion I look at it
as sort of a superpower if you can
access fear and like allow it to
overcome you and then kind of like take
all of that and like compress it and
like just hold on to it for a little bit
and then let it go all of a sudden it
disappears and you don't feel it anymore
you can do it through breathing you know
it's like breathing through it it's like
hopping an ice bath you breathe through
that kind of stress and it's hard to to
manage because sometimes you know you
feel like just depending on where you're
at you can't overcome that fear the way
you'd like but when you do it's the most
freeing feeling ever you don't all you
see is what you gotta do and you don't
see anything else